hey folks welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2016 I'm delighted to be
joined by Olivier panty re from Ubisoft
sir you are showing one of the many
virtual reality games that Ubisoft are
working on at the moment and Eagle
flight you guys were on during the press
conference couple of days ago what's it
been like getting reactions from people
and for seeing this game for the first
time so reactions are really amazing
people are amazed by all intuitive it is
to control the game but also how precise
you are can be in the game because we
are reusing the most of a VR the game is
rigged comfortable but you pick it up in
a few minutes and in a few minutes to
become an expect of lights you don't
need a complicated control so yeah
reactions are very good so far and so
you've been working at Ubisoft for a
long long time almost two decades you've
got your you know finger involved in
everything years Assassin's Creed too
far cry 2 the splinter cells and Rima
and tell me about the sort of the
challenge there is with virtual reality
with like with making a game like this
you said you did quite a lot of research
and development on this yeah or you got
off the ground so before we started the
project we need six months or of a
research on Viera I want to make sure
that we use the most of VR headsets and
and we are in general there was also
this problem of discomfort that can be
in viera so make sure that we can have
lots of motion and be very comfortable
for most and also use the most of you
are in terms of accessibility like being
very intuitive so everybody can pick up
and enjoy being a bear being a [ __ ]
playing of our Paris at the same time
being very precise so it can be very
precise Union you can go into tiny
passages like in the literal you can see
here so it's a it's a combination of
several elements that makes the most of
your its most VR games or at least a lot
of the VR games we're seeing early on
have tried to restrict motion as much as
possible you know it's all about sort of
small minut motion what what made you
guys go in the complete opposite
direction
I couldn't believe that via was doomed
rice in a way to have to be only seeded
xparent non-moving expounds I was
convinced that you it was possible it
should have been possible it would be
possible to have read so much on and and
live the dream of being a well being an
eagle flying and do that in VR so I went
up to the wall and through the wall and
we research with with studies to to
understand why that can be discomfort
and what we can do so we have many
techniques today we have the [ __ ] you
can see and the weekend the eyebrows we
have what we could do blind us with the
the black element the blackness that
comes on the sides dynamically depending
on certain conditions in fact it's when
you need it it's hiding your peripheral
vision right dynamically it's also about
the motion that is forward with no
inertia so there's lots of a combination
of elements that make it makes it
possible that's fascinating that the the
beak is actually an important sort of
young for it's not something to do with
how were like we we we have our noses
there at all times yes no our
equilibrium or something yeah so in fact
our brain is is used to see our nose all
the time and it groans us in the world
yeah envy are the issues that when you
put the view at set then you don't see
your nose anymore so we did join the R&D
phase we also lead another experience
while you are human and we added the
nose and it was really helping to grow
on the players and a pin with comforts
so we found the equivalent in a girl CL
universe the good ones your beak and its
really groaning you in the world and
gives you a referential or 20 for the
world to to to know exactly or to where
you are as I told you the game is very
precise with also helping you to to
gauge where you want to aim and I a
squint I Nicastro sorry got in your face
exactly yeah I got the chance to play it
and you watch that footage and it looks
like okay but will it really look that
good right Wang but it's really just you
look where you want to go you have the
controller which is doing like you know
you can shoot out those sound waves that
went online the multiplayer mode but
I mean immediately I was kind of
dropping down like into like those
alleyways and then coming back up out of
courtyards and there's like a sense of
momentum that feels awesome so we've
talked about the game and I guess in the
sense of like how it controls and and
virtual reality and all those important
questions which especially people who
owe a lot of the people who watch these
streams have never had the opportunity
to put those headsets on but let's shift
a little bit to the gameplay what
exactly is going on in ego fight it
seems to be like almost like a game of
football between a bunch of different
birds okay so in fact the full game as a
three parts let's say the first one is
called the free flight so it's for every
everybody to pick up the headsets and
enjoy exploring the city from a new
point of view the eager point of view
then we have a single player mode a
story mode and finally we have the
multiplayer mode so no multiplayer is
about it's called capture the prey so as
any girl you have to you have to capture
prey and bring it back to your nest to a
new ratio your little Eagles eaglets and
so there is two teams competing in Paris
to grab the the prey and deliver
deliberate first to the nest what's
Paris looks a little bit different we
see like ile-de-france and nacho down
here but it looks like there are many
humans around anymore yeah so the wall
is set 50 years after humans left the
city so nature is reclaiming the city
animals are getting back in the in the
city so there is actually a zoo I called
the zoo de vincennes close to to Paris
and the animals escape from that zoo and
that's why you can see giraffes and
elephants and zebras in the city when
during the serie so it's truly a nature
of taking back the city and it's not
it's not apocalyptic I don't like this
warranty rider it's really positive its
nature of taking back the city and
making it beautiful it's like Pripyat or
something or like Tokyo jungle it's like
a kind of like a good thing and so I
guess who are you playing against you
said like the multiplayer game are we
talking about playing online
predominantly I'm assuming because
virtual reality headsets it's not like
you have six of them lying around yeah
so that's another thing with you I we
really wanted to make to show that via
can be social
so it's a multiplayer game you have
teammates with you so it's two times of
two teams of three players its sixth
graders in total and it's a social
experience and so with your teammates
you can cover your teammate another one
can play the sniper only one can be the
the runner you know like he's grabbing
the prayer and runs into the city going
to say the tunnels and another the
bridges etc and yeah each player can
have its own strategy and tactics to to
make it happen and how do you sort of I
guess keep an eye on what your teammates
are doing a lot of the time because it
looks like this quiet it looks like
you'll have quite a lot to concentrate
on because you're going to try and make
sure you go in the right direction so
how do you sort of keep your eye on what
they're doing and work together as a
team so in VR you have a large field of
view though so it's very easy when you
climb up in the sky to see what is
happening that's what we we have in the
game in fact which shows Paris because
it's very organic it's a you have very
tight streets but sometime it's often is
very useful to climb in the sky and to
have a very good overview of the city
and where are your teammates where are
the opponents whereas the prey and it's
read that gameplay of a wake up in the
sky then diving into the Turner's diving
to get the prey and that allows you with
the large field of view to to see what
is happening and where everybody cool
and mike you said you played this packet
was a GDC or was it here at e3 it was
the oculus event before GDC so i dont
rember the because that implemented the
time yes oh it was okay yeah my just
didn't notice it was yeah it's natural
because you eat replace yet don't know
sleep cycle makes it feel like an
extension face right yeah as opposed to
just this huge block on your eyes right
maybe your nose just looks like a beak
when you're went from your perspective
maybe I just feel an eagle all the time
what did the moment-to-moment gameplay
feel like to you if you can go back then
and remember ya know the the multiplayer
mode that he was mentioning up pray yeah
pray yeah it rabbits yeah you pick up
the rabbits and then you want to just
it's like capture the flag essentially
but you know you have these sound waves
are shooting out right or is it maybe
not sound waves but it's in ways okay
yeah and then it you had another eagle
and a puff into like a cloud of feathers
but you know it
you want to get the rabbit but you as
soon as you escape you start you want to
like make it hard for people chasing you
or because then a lot of people be above
the building's waiting for you to come
back out and so a lot of times are going
through alleyways or up through these
like the cathedral addicts yeah they
kind of go through like the entire
building inside it almost no then you
know swoop down changing elevations it
it's fun to like be chased in that game
because you're just having playing mind
games with people that are red like
behind you but then also like you're
that's the last few seconds when you're
about to bring it back to your nest but
someone else was already like above you
waiting in queue life yeah it's almost
like we've seen a lot of like I guess
dog fighting or spatial dog fighting
games in virtual reality because it
seems to be a good fit it's like okay
you're walking around you're looking
around and but this is sort of a unique
game in that it's not just you against
you know targeting things it's more
about your movement within the world as
opposed to like what you're trying to
hit all the time yeah so it's all about
the dream of being a bird and a flying
over a non city a wonderful city our
controls are already on the fact that
you can move your head and it's
everything is done with your head and
that's why it's so intraday for
everybody to enjoy it and so precise at
the same time so space shooter in VI
it's it's great but it many may not be
as intuitive and as precise it's in
something else you can you use a drastic
etc or game as a more simple approach
but I will I'd like to compare it to a
spot you know the material model as as
rules that are globally fairly simple
but yeah there's a lot of depth like
soccer you you have to grab the grab the
prey and bring it back and you are very
precise ahead so we also wanted to set
apart from the from the other games yeah
and that was personally my dream of
flying I did
many and many dreams about flying since
I'm a child yeah I really wanted to have
more because dreams usually you dream
about a flame where it's two minutes 10
minutes and then in serps yeah I wanted
more so I wanted to fight away and we
are is a way to make my dream come true
and I'm sure made the dream of many
people come true as well as I as well
did you grow up in Paris as well or yes
exactly so this is perfect this is
exactly what is I guess I'm fascinated
to talk to somebody who was developed
and worked on so many games hughesnet
directing a sort of a virtual reality
only experience because there's lots of
games that are sort of using VR as well
but like this seems to be like you're
dead set on just like working within
this what are some of the most difficult
sort of obstacles you've had as a
director as a designer of this game to
try and make this something that people
can play and not feel like they want to
like get sick like something that makes
them feel positive and I opposed to
negative in fact so via is a new medium
it's a big challenge but I like
challenges and so it's it's great to be
able to develop a new platform and find
a you know those new challenges of
comfort and also on controls are we
going to make these the controls easy to
pick up your own on remand for example
we retried also to make the game
intuitive and easy to pick up and play
yea though you does lots of a deaf and
will play beauty and and very tough
challenges or so in the end in remanence
that's that's what we are aiming forward
so far for a girl right so those
challenges are very interesting in fact
to to discover a completely new medium
and a study the the best use we can make
and and and all of that and so when is
that I ocean on what platforms so it
will be released in fall 2016 and the
PlayStation VR oculus rift and HTC vive
awesome I will be a launch title for
PlayStation of your little bit I it's
undecided yet okay still friggin green
eyes wonderful thank you so much Olivia
for coming and showing a sequel flight
merci beaucoup and it's a good best of
luck with the rest of development as
well thank you awesome I thank you so
much about merci beaucoup to all of you
is well my French is terrible it's
better
desolate and we have I believe mr.
Schaefer in the wings to come on and
talk about another virtual reality game
he just wound himself so let's get him
on the talk of head psychonauts in the
rhombus of ruin in just a second stay
there you're watching the game spot
stage brought to you by airheads